call of duty advanced warfare there was
this guy who was on set to basically be
a technical adviser and he just kind of
sit off to the side and this guy was
[ __ ] the [ __ ] and they'd have this
whole scene after that you know blocked
out and scripted everything is like
alright guys you're going into battle
right now and then they had like this
whole Apocalypse Now thing your helmet
helicopter and you're like you're
yelling there's all this stuff and they
kinda look over and was like Mike
whatever the [ __ ] his name was like
anything you wanna say goes yeah you
could do like that they're like okay
anything you want to make us nobody be
saying [ __ ] there's like you know no one
you are if you allow your emotions to
become part of the equation you'll go
[ __ ] crazy and I love that notion of
like if I this can't be an emotional job
because if you start thinking oh I'm
gonna I'm gonna get on this helicopter
this huge machine of war and destruction
and these six guys that I know
I mean we're gonna ramp each other up
and we're gonna get down into the [ __ ]
and and statistically speaking 60% of
them are going to die and in in the
course of them dying they are also going
to deal out death and we're probably
each of them are gonna kill at least
five people you just can't do that so
it's just like alright target down
target down and she goes no one's saying
[ __ ] cuz you know your job remember
watching real footage once during the
early days I guess of the US invasion of
Afghanistan where it was from those
planes that that you know shoot these
these c-130 yeah and they're so they're
taking out people that are you know a
mile away and I remember the the the
complete emotionless like dispassion in
their voice where they were like we have
a target on the hill firing in three
okay we got him
next target and it was just like he was
like listening to someone sort through
the inventory of like a hardware store
you know it was just so and I remember
was very chilling but I remember
thinking how could you do that job and
not you would you ten minutes in you'd
cease to function if you didn't have
that as a as kind of like an emotional
barrier I would
counterpoint though did you guys see
those Navy videos that went up this week
UFO baby videos it's just the people in
the Navy being like bro what is that
it's like hey man I mean by definition
you're not identifying something very
true attempting to there you go nice one
[Laughter]
all right I guess that's our is that our
cold yeah is everybody recording yeah
hey assented to piggyback onto that that
specific video that you're talking about
was reference for call of duty modern
warfare so they brought us in they were
like alright so we're doing this because
I think the first one that I was on
there the first one with that I the
first one that I auditioned for was was
world at war which was not projected to
do very well and its sales weren't good
until they did the zombies and the whole
army of Darkness thing and that's what a
included that forever into that
franchise and really made that that yeah
that that's specific when I was like
this is stupid and campy because I
remember like because I played Medal of
Honor and then I played like a big red
one and all that stuff I was like
[ __ ] Band of Brothers this is great
and especially the one of the first
games that I ever did was Brothers in
Arms I was like I love that kind of
tactical first-person shooter thing so
but then we want to go the first game
that was ever cast in was modern warfare
they're like we want to show you this
footage because you're gonna be one of
the pilots I was one of the pilots on
the c-130 and their plane was like
really they're like yeah but this is
this is what these guys sounded like
like there he is boom he's down it's
just that and they were like we need you
to be as flat as possible and I was like
that's again the attention infinity
award especially this is not as the
disparage I meant on everyone from
sledgehammer or even
I can't think of their names they they
do wrong Treyarch Treyarch i you know it
started with Infinity Ward and this
thing was born out of Vincent's mind and
for it to be a almost a an escalation
from from Medal of Honor into Call of
Duty and everybody else just kind of
like got their chance they were like the
almost the guitar texts for [ __ ] Joe
Perry and then they decided to become
the guitarist for their own band and
they're all great and there's they're
huge studios but they're that no call of
duty has ever felt to me like what
Infinity Ward did it's always felt a
little derivative of even though I had a
blast with black ops that was great
it just was never never as good as
modern warfare especially my favorite
which is relevant to what we're talking
about today but I should intro the show
before we get there hello everyone
welcome to another episode of play watch
listen I'm Ilana pace I am joined by a
video game composer Austin Wintory tee
is next video game actor Troy Baker and
I should who I think a lot of people
missed the PSA even though I feel like
we talked about it Mike also does code
people like you guys I do yes
off the top of the show today I just
wanted to address that something super
shitty happened this week we are not
going to discuss that topic we're gonna
stay on topic but I did just want to say
to everyone who makes video games thank
you for your hard work thank you for the
stories that you create that a lot of us
get to experience that shape a lot of
people's lives do a lot of good things
so thank you for all your hard work we
you know couldn't be more thankful or at
least I couldn't I don't know what the
rest of you chumps but thank you alright
we're talking about remakes we're
actually doing it this week I've had
this Midgar background I think like
three weeks in a row and it's happening
I mean like stolen like stone yeah I was
gonna say but about Star Wars first I
wanted to breathe
it's still very good but we're not
talking about it um has anyone other
than Mike or I've been playing Final
Fantasy I still have it I still have it
yeah and I've only got I've not gotten
super far in this business opening train
I'm I'm where if I got to I am I'm at
the I'm sure like I'm I'm sure if you're
like a Final Fantasy 7 nerd you're
screaming at the screen and I respect
you and I would be the same valve games
but like I'm at the town where you get
the place you live next door to a guy
there's a landlady with a massive yeah
on the back of her head why apparently
you don't get a villain from Power
Rangers you know the with the wait a
minute spiky hair what was her name
remember well I know the landlady that
you're speaking about I don't know but
so she's played by yeah by the the main
the main big bad in the original Power
Rangers the I'm doing this is the worst
anecdote in the history I know what
you're talking about that lady's not
there's a person that she's an actress
who played another person she doesn't
face that was voice actors they'd be
working on multiple things I tell you
they do every time Mike how is it that
you fully missed out on final fantasy
like yeah that surprised me so yeah well
I was a PC gamer as a kid like I didn't
have Final Fantasy 7 on PC did you I I
see the only kind of exactly excuse yeah
right I guess the only kind of the only
kind Japanese game even that I remember
playing as a kid was male Gear Solid
like that was and my god is Metal Gear
Solid mind-blowing if you are a kid who
has no nod your anime Noach of like
Japanese culture at all like you played
Metal Gear Solid just blew my mind but
no I never I never really got into the
Final Fantasy games I remember like I
think trying ten at one point but like
that's not where it's a big sphere of
water right the sport they play in that
but yeah I just I never really JRPGs in
general just never got into them I was
played a lot of you know like Bioware
and Bethesda stuff but just never go
into the Japanese side of things which
I know it was immediately a whole
massive swath of awesome games I've
missed out on so for me it's exciting
because it seemed like different it
seemed like I could get the story but
via what I've from what I know is like a
more action focused version of the game
which is interesting how old were you
and you started playing games bike so I
was I was I was playing PC like like old
apogee style like Commander Keen and
kind of stuff like that when I was like
I guess like eight nine ten and then and
then but then in terms of actually like
being like a gamer who was into games
like no until I was like in my like mid
to late teens like I wasn't I'm one of
those rare game designers who didn't
kind of grow up obsessed with games
mainly because I think my parents didn't
want me playing games very much I
remember my mum like being like we all
want your waste your life playing capir
games and and I'm serving up every
Christmas and you know so I think what
now mom yeah yeah I've proved it to you
but but yeah it was so yeah I was like
Dreamcast is where I got into console
games in particular like that was my so
I basically have the tastes of someone
about 10 years younger than me in terms
of games in terms of nostalgia and stuff
I feel like Final Fantasy 7 is such an
interesting one because I would have
been maybe three when it came out five
four I was four I just did the math
batted it takes me a while but that one
was the the first Final Fantasy to get
extremely popular though I feel like you
know I want to say like maybe general
industry consensus is that six is the
best a lot of people obviously miss that
it's also not community consensus it's
general industry consensus which is a
whole other thing this is it's
definitely a huge thing in IGN when we'd
make those that one was very very heated
someone who couldn't make the meeting
sent an angry email being like I just
think it's like really [ __ ] up that
you guys didn't consider my favorite is
nine because it has this probably
because it's I was the right age to play
it but it's just got this like very
whimsical fantasy feel to it um it's
it's very pretty and the characters are
actually really happy where is like I
feel like
especially early and final fantasy 7 is
just just a [ __ ]
he's just rude and it's so weird to have
such an iconic character and everyone
acknowledges him as being so iconic and
he's just just kind of grumpy selfish
piece of [ __ ] who's just trying to make
money really it's just amok I assume you
guys you're a narc sigh yeah because a
lot of bad [ __ ] happens to him he
actually is a really interesting hawk
and I'd be interested to see if you
finish this game Mike what happens what
what you think of what happens in this
game because if you haven't played the
original
they kind of change
clouds I've heard that there's some like
it's a different ending right or it's
like it's only part of the original game
and it has like some weird choices I
just keep seeing these vague allusions
to like weird choices in the ending is
that what you mean like it's kind of yes
I think it's very different sorry good
change like is it is it one of those
where you feel like they've improved it
look I really respect what they did and
I feel like the audience is split very
50/50 on this and the reason than I
expected is because they kind of just
threw the word remake on its head it is
it's it almost feels like a sequel but
am I am I mistaken that they did
something that this game went through
multiple iterations and then I remember
being we were at game stops big
conference right and they were like they
just trashed everything they did and
they're they're completely redoing it
and they kind of threw everything away
and now they're I was like well I'm
everyone they because they showed this
first at e3 right it was it was the the
Sony press conference I was in the
audience yeah yeah yeah it was holy cuz
I remember the first time they showed
cloud I was like holy Sh a I think they
show the gun sword action was the first
thing those are the big the big sort of
labels and I was like are they are they
gonna do this and then I was like yes no
wait what if we did yeah what do you
know about the timeline of they rehired
a bunch of people to
we do a bunch of systems that I don't
think was actually story related I think
from the first or like for the first
iteration of what rehired from where it
was maybe halfway through and I know one
of them main job listings was someone
who could work on the battle mechanics
so I think it was probably mostly
gainfully related um an interesting
thing about you know I was very confused
about this game and if a lot of people
were they were saying it was going to be
episodic and I was like how does this
game work
episodic that doesn't make any sense are
you going to charge me the same amount
for several episodes of Final Fantasy
which can take a hundred hours to finish
maybe it's actually not too episodic
they've just split the game into I would
guess three pots and it is three full
games is the impression that I get I
think Final Fantasy 7 remake as it
stands is a very complete game I don't
imagine they they changed the story very
much I would I would think that the the
vision the two who worked on it
especially would had four I mean it's
very Kingdom Hearts really it's they
would have probably had a through line
from the very beginning but I I really
like what they did because like I said
it's not a true remake they flipped that
idea on its head and made it a sequel
remake in that it's the same characters
going through the same thing but
depending on how you look at it and
without getting into anything too
intensively like a different timeline I
just think it's very creative how is
that not just a remake then if it's the
same characters no I know she's
referring to like I don't I don't know
the original but there's definite like a
feeling of like walking into a party
where everyone's already been talking
for a couple of how it's like you have
this vibe as you're playing it like I
like there's little in jokes and stuff
and there's like I'm like previously as
well but it's not it's more subtle than
that just it turns of phrase that are
used there's a moment where he walks
into a room and a bad guy yells
something at him he says that's my line
and the camera holds for a second as if
that's a moment and it was like I is
that something where that was his line
in the original and they've taken that
line again doesn't that still land
squarely on this is a remake but it's
self-aware of its predecessor like that
I remember like James Bond until until
Quantum of Solace no bond film was ever
a direct sequel but the the first the
first non Connery hermit on Her
Majesty's Secret Service with George
Lazenby the opening scene is you know
him trying to rest loved her so much
what I love you so much I like that he's
non Connery as a would yeah well that's
all so the George Lazenby he gets
slapped by the girl he tries to rescue
her in the opening scene from drowning
on the beach and she slaps him and he
looks straight at the camera and goes
well that never happened to the other
guy and then they roll the main titles
which is full of shots of Sean Connery
and they had avoided showing his face up
and tell that like he's driving his Bond
car and it's like a close-up on his hand
a close-up on lighting the cigarette and
all that and it's like they were just
screaming you know we know it's not the
same we know it's not the same but just
Oh bear with us bear with us and I feel
like it's like an in-joke to to reboot
it's not it's not continuing it's like
trying to palette plans it feels simply
describing feels kind of similar it's a
degree yeah it's it's it's not I don't
want to call it a remake because it
challenges the idea of a remake
immensely dumb maybe me reading into it
too far you could argue against that
cohesively just fine but I feel like it
now that I've finished it
seeing the phrase remake on that box
ought to me is like huh it's like it
means something different from what they
did for this game which you know a lot
of people are really upset that they
changed some wish like well I keep
seeing it as my head has changed the
wood to be capital o capital e : make
because that's what they do with Kingdom
Hearts and it feels very Kingdom Hearts
they made yeah pretty much they made the
thing but they they altered it it's like
if someone edited the original script
and there's still two very different
versions of the same base
this is almost like a read like a reboot
it for sure is more of a reboot than a
remake but that is still kind of a
theory because we won't actually know
until the second one comes out so do you
think it's actually it would be more
accurate to what what is the I guess the
better question to ask is what is the
benefit then of including seven as as
opposed to now I understand why it like
take 13 right they did 13 1 13 to 2 or
13 3 it was a continuation of this IP
this franchise looking at 13 as an
individual thing versus going 13 14 15
at what point do you not just call this
Final Fantasy 16 that just happens to
have these characters and just happens
to have these world the way you want to
make about half as much money is that
what do you think that's what is its
rates I mean we could get into the whole
like discussion of like remakes as risk
management is definitely like I mean the
money things are very blunt kind of bad
way of putting it but it's risk
management it's with any remake it so
it's a risk based decision but then you
also immediately beg the comparison so
that could drive your Metacritic down
which strategy sails down which you know
there's there's all that are you not
just like potentially trading risk
I think Final Fantasy 7 being one of the
most iconic games of all time yeah was
always gonna get a lot of hype when it
was called the Final Fantasy 7 remake so
I understand that but it is also I even
feel like that's creative I feel like
there's this meta to the name that again
I could be reading into that isn't fair
but I really feel like it's a very much
I don't know it feels like endgame II to
me in some ways like it feels very like
it's the truth Final Fantasy sort of if
maybe there is a Final Fantasy I think
that was actually supposed to be six
who's gonna be the lost game the first
one was yeah that's the whole story
isn't it well yeah and till seven and
then it was like like it this is gonna
be just fine up to 15 we're doing great
but yeah I feel like the naming choice
like in terms of remakes
does make perfect sense to me like for
business reasons like you said remaking
and remastering things people are gonna
buy IP they know this is obviously a
huge thing in the film industry as well
the one question I've always had about
that is why ei doesn't do it
they won't remake mass effect they're
there they won't remaster mass effect
they're against it and my brains always
like you have this franchise that people
absolutely adore your EA why I have a
theory it could be wrong mmm no I might
disagree with them as I go on so
apologies if I do excellent so should I
can't wait so the business case is
deeper than just like name recognition
the business cases it's risk not just in
terms of like sales but in terms of
development so the great thing about
doing a remake or remaster is you know
the game you're making when you start
and that never happens when you're
making a game like there's so much
creative risk in terms of are we gonna
make a good game or you make a terrible
game is gonna sales not gonna sell is
the audience giving care or they're not
gonna care but also just are things like
can this dev team make this game you
know and that's really interesting when
you're in the process like pitching
projects around like yes you're trying
to convince people you have a cool idea
but you're also trying to convince them
that you like can make sure that you can
salaries are paid on time so that gets
done don't know who what team would make
that game and that well that's part of
it and I think that's the that's part of
it I think with with the other thing
though is with all risk management it's
also about the payoff so what I would
bet with someone like EA is EA is such a
mega publisher and they're making so
much money from their sports games they
probably have run the numbers and gone
we could make a Mass Effect remake we
know how much it would cost because we
know literally like how many meshes for
characters we need because we could just
rebuild everything as it wasn't again
not the Final Fantasy clever kind of
remake just a straight-up remake I only
did with Spyro where you just swap all
the assets essentially and then rebuild
all of the core gameplay code and
everything that's a very quantifiable
thing they can go okay Mass Effect will
cost exactly this amount that will take
this amount of time they also can make
some guesses about how it would sell
based on Mass Effect games were also on
like Dragon Age and we'll their history
with RPGs I bet they've run the numbers
and gone we could pay 200 people to make
this
we would make X but we could pay those
same 200 people to make something new
and either we make no money or we make
so much more money than we would from
Mass Effect 2 remake I mean this is
something people often don't realize
that when you're a publisher and you're
managing a whole staple of different
games you're trying to get the hit
nobody wants in the publisher side
publishers don't want like the safe game
that sort of makes a decent return on
its investment yet they want Minecraft
they want a also has a push for games as
service exactly because that's where the
money is yeah if you're ranking games
are service yes a lot of games of
service are gonna fail some you know
there's obviously things like anthem
which had not a great launch but if
anthem had worked it would have made
billions over its lifetime like so it's
it's that kind of I imagine that's the
game they're playing where they're going
we can make mass of fact we make we'd
make money but probably less money than
we could theoretically make if we take a
bigger risk with the same team members
so it's a safer bet but it's not
financially for them they'd rather make
the big bets yeah I think yeh has almost
screwed themselves because ultimate team
is the most profitable thing ever they
make so much money from Ultimate Team
and I mean when you look in the inner
workings of Ultimate Team you know they
have a system that they don't have to
pay for marketing because they market to
everyone who plays the game you have
basically cards that you don't have to
pay for printing it gets just this
constantly infinitely renewable resource
that doesn't cost that much to run even
and they make so much money from it
every single year that it's just I feel
like if you have execs looking at
Ultimate Team being like why can't we
make that on every single one of these
games why don't we why is that not
working in this and the way that
Ultimate Team even came about is really
fascinating in the fact that the game's
community accepted that is this very
long history of like perfect things
happening where I think it originally
didn't actually launch with the game it
was DLC and then it was eventually
packaged in and then it just slowly
became this addition to FIFA annually
that never came across as very
aggressive microtransaction heavy
because of the way that they paced that
out which was completely unintentional
but I feel like yeah EA specifically is
sort of screwed when it comes to return
because you have a company that is run
by business execs and not game
developers which is always
a huge indication of how they're going
to make games and what games that going
to make especially if you look at the
board of any company plus it publicly
traded so that means they care about the
stock market so they care about making a
lot of money and if you even to your
stakeholders you show them well yeah we
have this thing that makes billions of
dollars a year they're like why can't
you make that across the board figure
out how to do that across the board they
don't care about the game just do more
of that or even the calumny even like
the autistic argument right let's let's
let's forget the business like the
really hierarchy hierarchically very
very business folks guys the guys below
that the guys who actually like you know
really care about games or make cool
games even for them what's the upside if
I make a Mass Effect remake and it does
well like excellently well like like as
well as theoretically it could do maybe
that's enough of a head win that they
can make a Mass Effect sequel but that's
kind of a franchise that's maybe played
out like it's a tough thing to do
whereas if they going back like a bunch
of smaller projects or you know like you
know in the kind of five to ten million
range which is small for EA um if they
if they back a few of those kind of
things maybe one of those is the next
Mass Effect no one wants the old Mass
Effect the reason to do a remake is
usually either to to test the water on
like an IP to go well should we
something like Spyro Activision
basically she's doing say again sorry I
think that Isis is doing yeah that's a
great example right like um the only
reason to make a crisis remake right now
is to see if the crisis could be and but
make no mistake the only reason you
check if crisis works as a franchise now
is because we're having a resurgence of
first person shooters making so much
money in multiplayer so there's always
like the long-term you need the you need
the the you need they need to be
spending their money in the direction
where they think there's more money
otherwise business sure I guess in my
head it was just Mass Effect is
guaranteed to sell well because I feel
like everyone wants that and I feel like
it's good PR for ei like you would
that's something that they would want
and there's some they make some really
odd piaces I don't know if I've spoken
about it on this show but I feel like I
bring it up sort of often the EA
originals program outside of unravel
which does not count because
it fell under different umbrella ei
doesn't profit from that program they
publish the games the develop developer
keeps the IP EA pays for marketing and
they basically get their money back but
any profit goes directly to the devs for
a triple-a publisher that deal is insane
yeah that means that a way out and three
I've been to others I think had all of
the money that they've made go straight
to those studios yes I think so
it's relationship building as well right
so I mean that's the main benefit of M
is like if one of those games blows up
or one of those developers wants to make
something bigger next then it's good to
have a back and forth between between EA
and them so yeah makes it I think it's
like I say it is it's a very generous
deal it's incredible and I feel like
nobody knows that and the fact that EA
doesn't talk about it seems nuts to me
because it's so good of them to do and I
feel like EA does have negative PR as
everybody yeah that's like everybody the
sort of quote standard gamer if that
even is a thing but EA is a lot of
people's favorite publisher to hate you
know like it's for years and years just
like the the Midas touch on everything
and because that's been I think for so
long like I would say a full decade may
be long other people of hated EA I've
always been like you like that games
though right yeah I mean I'm the company
for the longest time they loved them
float yeah someone's played him yeah
absolutely I mean they had mass we
reckon age I would buy the [ __ ] out of
anything Mass Effect even after
Andromeda which I you know because I was
sad by it because it didn't suck
horribly it sucked in like noticeably
difficult ways and then it had so much
beautiful potential in these other ways
and I was like aha
this is killing me yeah this man the
first three is just one of the best like
gaming experiences I've ever had and if
they if they remade that I would I would
just advise on like everything I've got
just just just as a as a they're
incredible
throwing throwing flowers at the stage
kind of nice on switch dude
here's the quote that that's a that's a
different point which I could understand
like if you bring it to a new platform I
understand but if a game is that good
can it not just hold up like what it
what is the reason for remaking it
rebooting it reira leasing it massive
one sort of does not hold up half and
but it's aging out in that stuff is that
really just not really so that's that
the combat is pretty obtuse it's just so
distracting like it feels like there was
a really big generational divide in
terms of tech in the middle of the
releases cuz two and three are so much
more polished and so much more current
gen quote feeling by comparison the
first one feels like an old game that's
really good and the second and third
especially the third feel like recent
games yeah you know that are like they
almost are practically just barely
passed to the release cycle by did one
existed one krauser generation is that
what happened with one was that in
development before PS I think that it
was an incorrectly you had this cool
thing where when you would then port to
the new platform to keep you a save file
you would have to answer a series of
questions so that it would transfer
between the two consoles it was
originally an Xbox exclusive as well
that's true which I've most recently
played it on PC and with Mass Effect my
thing is I always tell people play a one
on the easiest difficulty gets through
it I still really love that story and
then play the others normally really
it's really hard to do like a triple-a
the first title in triple-a franchise is
tough like like yeah that's you often
get that the second one you know how to
make it probably you're in the middle of
a console generations no one's throwing
you Hardware 8003 it's a great example
great example yeah a brilliant concept
that even when I was playing through
that I was like the second game's gonna
be great
yeah but but I would say that what they
did between 1 and 2 was they didn't
trust that the franchise was good enough
because everyone was like I had just too
repetitive too boring I was like okay
then let's swing super far over to the
other extreme and now let's make it GTA
now let's make it simply I don't give a
[ __ ] about collecting art from my
uncle's house like I don't I don't need
to do those things and it every
assassin's creed since has lost the
charm of the original one which was just
like it's fun to climb up high take a
look around and then from that height
killed that guy that's fun and it just
it became well now we have to do this
and now we have to constantly like just
trust the fact that you're you're a good
game but going back to what I was saying
as far as like why do this to begin with
if you go oh my god that game was so
good it was so amazing was so incredible
is that a qualifier it or is saying for
that time it was a qualifier or it cuz
like you look at movies you're like man
that movie still holds up like I could
still watch that movie and today it is
still just as good as it was then
or is it like it was really good for
that time and does that determine its
overall greatness like just as you're
saying it kind of doesn't hold up or
whatever can greatness of a game degrade
over time yes I don't think so well here
I'll let me give the one sentence answer
so I don't think that it's that the the
greatness has degrade it's the the the
aiming sort of zone of what you know in
which greatness Falls for a player
shifts somewhere else you're scoring on
a curve is what you're saying it's like
it's like if you're looking at a map and
greatness is this big circle on the map
you've shifted where greatness is
because tastes changed technology
changes and that informs taste and and
so it's like the the whole greatness of
its time to me feels like it was because
it was great relative to every
thing that was going on there and the
only way to evaluate it is to literally
essentially travel back in time because
now you're comparing it against things
that it never had any awareness of you
know what I'm saying and our and our our
focus has changed okay here's what I'm
gonna bring it back there are so many
parents right now and I'm one of them I
can't wait to sit Traveler down for the
first time and he's already building
anticipation for this like he
understands the music he understands the
characters but for the first time when
he can actually sit down and watch Star
Wars mm-hmm that you you can instantly
go I did it by the way you're welcome
you can instantly go well look special
effects have gotten better what as
compared to has gotten better this world
is now all of this but there's still
parents that go oh my gosh that I have
to you have to watch started was even a
bit in this disaster he's like I'm gonna
set my son down and we're gonna watch
Star Wars and kids still go that flight
there there's so many reaction videos of
kids first finding out that Darth Vader
was Luke Skywalker's father just like
that's fundamentally a problem the
difference I would say the difference is
Star War the act of watching movies
hasn't changed since you were a kid so
wrecked your technology it's it's
ultimately like the the mode of
interaction is what shifts I think
that's what Aegis games more than
anything is we are still in the arms
race I think if you sat Traveler down
and showed him a silent movie his
reaction would be different to someone
who watched a silent movie when they
were out like the idea the sense of the
medium has shifted I think I think I'm
still have value for him he's still
watching goes that's really like he'd
still like things about it in the same
way as he would like if you put Mario 64
in front of a modern game he never
played right they'd still think it was
cool they'd still think the animation
was fun they'd still find it colorful
and exciting but the mode of interaction
which you like there's this whole
conversation I think very much you know
when it comes to remastering Mass Effect
I don't want to forget about
all the people who have never played
Mass Effect because they're aging into
games and I've always had this thing
where if you look at the sales results
every month GTA 5 and minecraft
generally always in the top 10 selling
video games like it's very uncommon that
they aren't and for the longest time I
was like how who doesn't own these games
and then you remember that there are
millions of people aging into video
games every year and what a TA in
Minecraft do they update their control
mechanics as they constantly have
updates and you know very extensive
fundamentals for those two games in any
case but when it comes to something like
Mass Effect I think a lot of it centers
on the experiences of that person so if
you put traveler in front of exclusively
Super Nintendo games to the first year
and then he plays fortnight the next
year and then he goes back to Super
Nintendo it's gonna be a shift it's like
what is this I know parents who've done
that by the way I know parents in astana
logically raised their kids so yeah like
like snez till five then you get don't
you ever ever call it that again what
the [ __ ] you know I'm with you Troy well
I'm partially with you it doesn't offend
me but it does sound very bizarre yes
muga dr drum cast likes I also have a
likes I have a I'll go hard y'all I
don't care
oh my gosh like Star Wars still holds up
is that some things are transcendent of
time like there's no denying that but
that's where I say that's why I like if
you think of it as the the map analogy
like if you put a pin on the map and
then you draw a circle and then you
shift your circle to the left you can
potentially still shift it wear that pin
it has not left the circle but a bunch
of other stuff will have so it's like
that's interesting or whatever you know
it's not a whole hundred percent
migration because your argument saw your
is that there a classic kind of Keystone
thing because that's true of like if you
show traveler that like ten best-selling
sci-fi movies that came out in the five
years after star wars bet they haven't
aged as well right like maybe there is
maybe else's right maybe you could
transcend your pointing oh you sure
there's even like there's there's movies
that I've tried to show like I'm
probably speaking to most people here
Austin maybe I don't know but there are
certain movies that came out in the late
80s early 90s that read dawn prayer
that's that's mid 80s but like Red Dawn
terrified me because it wasn't a movie
it was a [ __ ] training video it's
like this is going to happen we're gonna
look out the window of our school and
we're gonna see Russian paratroopers
dropping into our fields and taking over
I mean that's that's the zeitgeist
that's where we live so I believe that
there's some things that are contextual
right but I also wouldn't say that Red
Dawn is one the greatest movies of all
time I would say dude it's such a good
movie Back to the Future still holds up
awesome
yeah it's a perfect movie die hard
perfect mozzies Ghostbusters perfectly
but I what's so funny though is that I
can look at III feel that also Hunt for
Red October John McTiernan and John de
Bont it was the same die hard team right
Wolfgang Petersen directed wait Wolfgang
Petersen did I just remember the amazing
language shifting scene not just the
best push in the only other one they did
is that direct the Wolfgang Petersen did
their first one that's what that's the
air first one is kind of a movie in like
10 days Wow I think everyone
[Music]
100 points 100 points if you can tell me
who the fired composer was it was like
Miami Thomas did Howard sorry sorry
James J wasn't Howard no no it's it's a
brilliant comes to miss typecasting well
what do we do with these 100 points if
we get them what can I can cash them in
for like custom emoji or whatever no I
know I know yeah I know this one I know
this one I know this one uh it's it's a
he died nope nope a non Connery Randy
Newman you gotta play to me Randy Newman
and you can hear it and it's by an
appeals to bridge oh don't you worry
bout their budget that was Michael on
this talent for all this yeah do it the
context when Randy's score floated out
after it was tossed Hans Zimmer who was
pretty fresh on the scene goes hey I
thought I was supposed to be the
kick-ass action guy it's it is a because
a full-on crazy like ballbuster of a
score the Big Dipper you fight it gonna
hear this I wanna watch this
but not only can you find it but on
YouTube people have married it into the
scene that's what I won't you can see
how it works and you can see why he got
fired because the score is amazing but
he approaches it kind of like it sounds
closer to Independence Day or something
where it's it's a little slightly bit
campy and so it treats the president
like a superhero instead of like in a
Americana film isn't that air force why
did I watch a different like I was Troy
Singh and to this day it's will tell you
Harrison Ford comes on in the music it's
it's almost like Superman and it feels
like I'm mr. president I want to see the
whole movie with that score no Pam
Pam will tell you right now I could walk
in she could she could literally walk
through like what what music is going
through your head every day and she'll
be like theme for Air Force One like
there's three things that constantly I
can even [ __ ] with a little bit I don't
know because that's that's like one of
the like the tenements of knowing Pam is
is that she constantly has the theme for
Air Force won't go through a head I feel
like you get [ __ ] done you would be the
other one arm again and there's there's
like three movies that she will
constantly watch all the time she'll
only watch Armageddon Air Force One or
Horrible Bosses they're like you get
through but those not lost really but
but the other thing that the other
musical thing that's hilarious is if I
want to [ __ ] with her I'll just walk up
and go to fold 6:01 it she can't she has
to finish the song from wherever I could
do anything from lame is and she would
be like you know I like a fighter I can
let it let you have your solo you know
it's funny don't worry it's gonna be
close enough to mine my favorite my
favorite Jean Valjean is actually Liam
Neeson I've no heard his version he
didn't sing it it was it was the victim
door
and it's it's a it's a fascinating
fascinating version of that but that the
all right love it go the the version
you're talking about yes Liam Neeson yes
it's a remake scored by Randy Newman
scored by Baz Apollodorus who also
scored Hunt for Red October and I took
you off of talking about hunter at
October and now we're back in so that is
your magic shelf by the way the musical
knowledge you you can tell me who the
[ __ ] composer Oh Mike he really does
know yeah who was the by the way
watching this there's one there's one
advantage like he's watching us as
opposed to just listening to this is you
can actually see Austin not googling
Austin I think that's great
did you guys did you do you guys not
just go to the magic premonition device
and wish to be an adult was that not how
work for you guys no I was 10 year olds
I was Larry just went straight child to
adult I just woke up one morning I was
there was there like a carnival machine
and you put in a thing and you squeezed
it it also a perfect movie except for
the fact that she is 100% pedophile
that's true it's the whole it's the
whole self perk thing with they're like
wait there's a hot older woman it's
another guy nice we really do cover
everything I was even resisting bringing
up grey dawn as Troy was talking about
red dawn so well I did about you can
like Austin if we're using
your example of like sort of a something
that rotates where some things you can
still play forever and and some things
you can't I think that that's harder for
video games probably easier for film but
do you think that there's a point where
in film as well
we as time goes on and we have a more
modern Bank of films that we've seen
Star Wars will eventually age out or do
you think that's permanently going to
hold up you think that comes a day when
the technology has exceeded so
exponentially when it comes to
filmmaking that only watched all of that
new stuff they eventually go to watch a
new hope they can't or is it going to
just stay I have a thought but what do
you say it's right I was I was gonna say
I want to answer after you because I
have something to add after go ahead -
you know all segments reuse your time
Austin we're not going to cut you all my
short we always I think my gut tells her
it's hard to say the Star Wars is one of
the brilliant things about Star Wars is
the thing that tends to age movies
really fast is their visual effects and
the reliance on practical effects
throughout Star Wars has always been one
of its big sort of like vaccines against
aging only half counts he just pulled
out not booked of Star Wars Jedi folio
which is actually probably very nice out
book I can actually tow to tow with you
on this one for once can't wait oh he's
gonna get books you want to Star Wars
book off 100% have you guys on this doll
was book off you have no idea the Star
Wars books I have you are are you
[ __ ] kidding me well McQuarrie I
think I have that kid in starting with
the 1977 concept school just will just
jump to this shrink-wrap sydney sleeping
up right now okay I'll open this
immediately boys boys you're both cute
you're both cute no sir I would oh no
now Alana's getting off into it I don't
i guys i can't play in this you guys are
playing with Lego that I don't have
understood Star Trek okay now you're
just oh there you go Wow okay raise the
bar that's my pressive that's good
a two-volume Wow hey Laurie that was a
two-volume ralph mcquarrie that Ilana
just pulled out for all of our podcast
listeners yeah so the the the the the
the long and short of it is I think
visually it ages incredibly well and it
probably always will because practical
effects are just always gonna you know
models are models they're just they're
always gonna look good like I don't see
how that can age but even more
importantly stop kids can't watch the
prequels is well though I mean those are
already aged I mean they were a right
within a year because they're or
immediately the reliance on CG is always
gonna be a problem and that was why it
was so interesting in the 80s when all
the Star Wars imitators came out and
we're using the tech that Star Wars
invented but not as cleverly and they
instantly looked not as good it's the
same with Jurassic Park movies but again
tangents avoiding the bait of all those
tangents the the the thing that I think
more importantly will help Star Wars
from aging relative to so many others is
that it's so grounded in these Universal
archetypes and themes it's the same
reason why I look and I say well there
are you know in innumerable works of
literature that are vastly older than
like electricity as a modern and we and
we still go to them and we still learn
from them and we still appreciate them
and so I don't think I think there are
things that just the get to the kind of
truth of what it is to be human in a way
that will make them forever part of our
kind of vocabulary
I mean Shakespeare on stage is still
amazing and transcendent if to
understand Shakespeare you have to put
effort in no is that true I mean
Shakespeare and thinking it was a
complete waste of my time it's like I
don't know why I need this until the
moment that I understood it and I had I
got it tattooed on me I had this like
moment of holy [ __ ]
he has written a motion without telling
me the emotion describing that and just
like oh the the shattering moment the
glass shattering moment that I remember
having with Shakespeare where I realized
what he had actually done and how he had
described things that maybe I had felt
to some degree in the most poetic way
without being like I am sad like it's
just I just have this incredible thing
but it takes effort to buy into and I
would actually say some books have aged
sure we have say Odyssey which people
will know forever and probably be forced
to read in school hey easy easy not for
us to get to may have the privilege but
I think that there are a lot of cases
where books are really hard to read of
course
head for Atlas Shrugged I mean those are
[ __ ] tomes but do you think that's an
age issue is that a nine Rand issue like
even Shakespeare Shakespeare is an
interesting analog to bring out because
it he was writing that he has a
technical element to his writing that
was contextual the reason why that a lot
of the jokes a lot of the puns are
pointing to the people specifically of
that time in that place where they were
standing versus where those people the
the the where the common folk would
would be versus the stalls were the you
know the elites the proletariat versus
you know the the upper echelon so I mean
he wrote contextually to to the time and
even the fat I am dead you know is is to
be able to convey to the audience what
is happening right now because some
people would be like well I don't know I
I don't understand this is such a new
language that was happening so that
doesn't age and it does take a huge
buy-in but that is a version of
technology that has obviously we're able
to we now have camera language we now
have visual effects we all have these
great things that we can incorporate to
sell the fact
oh that guy just died he doesn't have to
go I am dead but there's things that
when you Ilana you said
will it age out because of technology I
think and this is this is I'm bringing
it back to games the fact that if every
game is contingent its greatness is
contingent upon a mechanic or a
technical thing it will always age out
because you look at Godfather which is
look at what we're able to do camera
wise visual effects wise everything that
movie is still great because it's set in
a specific period of time it says what
it is it's not supposed to be a modern
date thing and it's just perfectly
flawlessly done into this great story
about family and that will never age out
it will never be look at the bad camera
work look at the bad dialogue look at
the back it's just it's it's still it's
it's perennial but for me the point for
me is the Godfather was directed in an
age where shock reaction shot and
Composition had existed for decades
right in terms of as film language the
rules of what was it what's the Russian
movie where they had the fur where they
experimented so much with shot reverse
shot with the pram going down the cellar
was called that what there was a stir
they were just talking about this that's
a name exactly you talk yeah
it's called it's not the one that's also
not see it's the other one there's one
that's know anyone that's KKK and one
that's Russian and they basically three
of those movies say again the big three
the big thing they invent but but like a
lot of like what the language of those
and that's my thing as I guess it's like
if the Godfather had been made at a time
where we didn't really necessarily know
exactly how an establishing shot should
work it was where we will if if a game
predates twin-stick controls that's you
know that's a fundamental part of the
language that it's missing out on and
that's where we may be different I feel
like we're still figuring sure but you
could also say that Coppola pushed
against that language and he broke he'd
he didn't break because breaking the
rules implies a lack of knowledge it's
ignoring them the fact that he was like
no I'm gonna I'm gonna stay on this shot
and I'm gonna do a slow push in because
what I'm trying to understand what I'm
trying to sell and this is
there was no language for this
beforehand is that we are slowly
understanding the mind of Ito we're
slowly understanding the position and
that we're gonna we're gonna match that
with a shot of Al Pacino and doing the
same thing as like now you understand
that he's moving in this position as
well it's it's I I understand it's like
oh now we have an analog so now we have
a d-pad or now we have an analog stick
and a d-pad so we can now use these
mechanics and being able to create a
game but it's it's the same thing like
every time that they do something all
those the the the touchpad for the for
the ps4 it's like where's the new
mechanic or we're gonna have the speaker
come out of it and where it's when you
when you build a game around tech you
are invariably inexorably tied to that
tech and it will never be anything about
that but I mean that understands I don't
mean so I don't mean the gimmicky stuff
I mean the fact that like the a button
is jump on an Xbox controller but other
language since Palin so if you play a if
you played a game on a control like that
before halo the same as like cool if I
remember after Call of Duty came out and
there was massive every first-person
shooter that pre-existed on their
settings menu had to add like switch the
controls to Call of Duty layout right
there's those kind of language it's it
may be the shot thing is a bad example
language the language of games the way
we were playing inverted right yeah
there's a gamer what you meant Troy then
when your stalkers you said a game that
bases itself on like where it's conceit
is entirely based on mechanics that's
different than bait then what you guys
are talking about because the first
thought I had was a game that I suspect
will forever age well but I will just
time will tell is portal but that's a
completely mechanics like the novelty in
charming yes it was it was charming
right it was mario mario society for
sure my head goes to is something that i
don't think will ever stop being
enjoyable to play because they focus so
hard on making sure those mechanics were
perfect for what they did and focus so
hard on making sure that jump felt right
on whatever environment you're jumping
on or whatever else
whereas you know i always make the case
for I don't think graphics aged as badly
as certain mechanics can but video games
are in a really
unique position where that's concerned
and that the amount of change we've had
in the last 20-30 years versus film in
the last 20-30 years obviously video
games are a much newer exponential
johnstrom dramatic so and the density of
those choices as well like if you look
at Mario you're dealing with something
which has Direction two directions and
jump and it's also very stylized versus
realism right so if you have something
that's realism you look at like Silent
Hill or Resident Evil you're like holy
[ __ ] they were going for real not
stylized and Mario it doesn't it's not
supposed to be a real guy it's supposed
to be caring
I actually think portal is the best game
ever made that's my hot take video game
ever made I mean if portal is realistic
it at least still very distinctly
focuses on a visual language these
colors mean these things these walls do
these things like everything at least
serves a purpose to guiding you through
puzzles in Portal where is something
like I'm trying to think of a very
realistic game that's aged really poorly
in terms of visuals I guess I don't care
about visuals a lot of the time like I I
appreciate something if it is a new one
has aged badly despite the same I'm
playing it for the first time Wow
brilliant it's so funny the voice acting
is just incredible the dialogue oh my
god Shenmue I caught like I was this
like my favorite game is Deadly
Premonition it's a bad video game but I
absolutely adore it shen made like taps
into that same like weird bizarre thing
where you're just talking to these very
strange people who are written very
strangely the dialogue oh my god and yet
it is that cultural or is that like what
what is that which pot like the release
of the writing and the performance
everything do you think that's like it's
what determines well specifically for
Shenmue I think what happened was that
they tried to cram so much into that
game for the time period in which it
came out and it was revolutionary at the
time basically someone just send me a
chat yeah I'll see was trying to subtly
tell us these let me make a point for
approximately 13 minutes just still
write down the clock there around
everything that all the games are kind
of pointing to which and then Shenmue is
a counterexample is it seems like
complexity is a challenge by which I
mean games and movies I guess that kind
of go for incredibly complex specific
stuff cut ones that arguably the ones
that have stretched the medium and are
original and try different things those
ones are trickier they can't happen with
a this they can struggle with ageing
whereas things like portal Tetris Mario
those were not the most complex games of
their era but they definitely had they
followed an unidentifiable as well right
no one would say Star Wars was like a
high arts kind of nerdy independent
movie it wasn't independent movie but it
was it was also nerdy but it was kind of
like it was going it was it was talking
about family and friendship and love and
our place in the universe like it was
big theme stuff so in that way kind of a
classic kind of simple I guess simple
but not as a pejorative simple in a
positive way I wonder if that's part of
this can I just harp on that for a
second please please all to me is the
highest possible achievement one
simplistic is the pejorative oh that's
interesting that might be my own little
sort of language there but to me
simplistic is condescending simplistic
is I have to dumb this down because you
won't get it otherwise simple shows its
lack of trust what which shows lack of
trust that's why you do that yeah we're
we say
hey how you doing I mean traveler having
conversation joy it's fine we're hug it
out hey traveler was like I I really I
have dogs on simple versus simplistic
yeah all the lost of us Cod's are loving
this Oh will you say good night buddy I
know it's genetic but yeah my go-to for
like simple is like equals mc-squared
right like that's it's about time we go
to the rule the relatives also very
important when it comes to marketing its
including for video games no you know
the game dream daddy mm-hmm the dad
dating simulator I thought that was
something on Grindr go ahead that game I
mean sure it came from game grumps you
have a very big install base but the
share ability of that game because of
the conciseness in which you could share
a lot of information about it was key
for marketing that game and that you
call it dream daddy that immediately
gives you an image you see the image and
it's also the dad dating simulator they
managed to make it an AK room for Dadd
yes I think so it's even the acronym is
dad that's great
it's my concept right film call it high
concept the kind of Air Force one die
hold on the plane
got it I'm already gonna buy my ticket
marketing is most effective when you can
share something with the least
information possible and I think that's
why Twitter is such an interesting
medium is you can tell if something's
going to go viral or whatever else based
on how accessible it is to a large
number of people so yeah like dream
daddy is in theory simple in terms of
how you can market it and how quickly
you know what it is and you get an
understanding of what you're signing up
for if you buy that game but
doesn't mean it's simplistic or dumb
because it's actually sort of a creative
game with very heartfelt characters and
beautiful art and etc and yeah I think
simple is a huge credit to something and
I mean George Lucas I feel like he's
pretty intentional about that and the
way he talks about Stahl was is he's
just like well I basically just looked
at religion and picked all the major
green daddy will outlive Star Wars
that's remember recall a kind of
post-mortem on the successive Fez
sighting specifically the the
shareability of gifts of the rotation of
the world on Twitter was like half of
the marketing success of that game it
was like it was so shocking and in
exciting to see the world move and and
you and Anthony Moss yeah exactly you
instantly are like I get I get how the
puzzles of that game work and I'm in
yeah there was a great example I hope I
get the artist right a pope was hiring
an artist to do something and he wanted
a demonstration of his greatness there
was Giotto I think I remember anyway to
demonstrate his greatness he freehand
drew a perfect circle and that was I
remember the movie sphere said
simplicity shows perfection and art like
that's what a great thing to be able to
do is like freehand to be able to do so
the most simple thing shows a great
amount of intelligence and skill along
in my face they heavily applied that log
of things she could draw a circle with
no trouble painting and I've drawn I
just don't have a steady hand in the
slightest so whenever I see someone even
draw a straight line I'm like you know
what wizardry is this are we at the
point where I'll just have to just
before you have to leave did you want to
tell us your story last week that I
caught you off on a movie don't worry
about it just tell the story no story
how did it come so the story is so out
of like the blue
because all I was going to talk about
was how in the movie I remember watching
it and hearing music at the beginning
and going that's music from the Julie
Taymor movie of Titus and then and then
it turned out what had happened was that
the composer was basically ordered by
the studio to rip off elliot goldenthal
music from tony like a temp track cool
it was temp yeah I was at empathy he
think nothing he did he was writing
music even while they were shooting and
yet they were like now we this piece and
he and it got so close that Goldenthal
sued Warner Brothers and won I remember
I was subscribing to The Hollywood
Reporter and variety dailies physical
magazines in those days I remember
opening it up before I had heard the
results of the lawsuit because of course
it was big news in composer land and I
open it up and there's a full-page ad
Warner Brothers bought as part of the
settlement that says we apologize for
our abuse of Elliot Goldenthal
music and Warner basically had to kind
of take the fall for that and and the
joke was that Goldenthal made more money
by not scoring the 300 when siva bleah
Tyler Bates did by doing so I don't know
if that's true but if you buy the album
like if you go on Spotify now it'll say
like variations on elliot goldenthal
next to the tracks as part of the
permanent thing and only a physical
album so yeah I don't remember how we
were in the world of like copyright or
IP or something and we were deep in
India we were can I ask you a quick
question awesome before we wrap up do
you think that um scores or soundtracks
could ever have the need to be remade
and I asked that question coming from a
person who likes a good
I had an emo phase and I liked a good My
Chemical Romance and I listened to them
on Spotify and it's the audio is
noticeably less equality than I would
want it to be now that's just the taste
you've developed in these intervening
years that's although I think Mike's not
wrong like some music remarkably and
never seems to age in that way like
Bowie or the Beatles or like there's
some people that are doing things that
were that are technically very dated and
yet they transcend time in
in such magical ways but funny enough
that you asked me that because when we
were talking about Final Fantasy 7 I had
kind of queued up and then and then and
then I forgot about it to to gripe about
of all the things for them to cut
corners on on that game the [ __ ]
music is all still sampled Orchestra
despite the fact that they spent a
fortune remaking every aspect of it and
it's clearly samples trying to sound
like a real Orchestra and it is also one
of the most beloved video game scores
ever written like Nobuo Uematsu is
routinely talked about as the john
williams of video games and like and
they even did a live from Abbey Road
with full orchestra Final Fantasy
concert slash live stream a couple of
years ago and like Final Fantasy was
also the first ever video game concert
with proper Orchestra at Disney Hall
like 20 years ago at shortly after
Disney Hall even open it's like they
have so much tied into that music that
in this specific title their brand
overall musically like there's just so
much there's so much kind of gold and
heritage there and then I listened to
bits of the because I was excited I
thought oh it's gonna be interesting to
hear all these classic bits but kind of
properly produce now that they have
budget and bandwidth and all that and I
went back and I was like that's those
are you know that's a Spitfire library
that's in a samples are when I was like
this is my number of nine fools me I was
like this fired up back in 1997 but that
means that you were looking for remakes
of songs that at the time as you said
did not necessarily have the bandwidth
to be of a certain quality which I feel
like probably happens in Troy's industry
as well and that yeah like if we're
talking about shénme some of the issues
with the voices in that game that they
the audio quality is so low because they
do so much in - mu and Suzy make man I
got
over that [ __ ] so yeah and start
contrast right before they full or you
know got gobbled up and disappeared
LucasArts remastered Monkey Island hmm
and it's one of the best remasters of
all time because that if you hit like
f12 or something it will crossfade to
the original inhaler did that what's in
the world did that they did that where
the music was all MIDI because the
original was like 91 or whatever right
so it's like it was done using this a
very innovative MIDI system at the time
that Peter McConnell helped developed
called the I'm Muse which is like super
interactive you know MIDI synth music
but it was all supposed to sound like
you know steel drums and pan flutes and
stuff because it's Monkey Island so they
went and recorded my friend and
colleague who was at the time at
LucasArts Jesse Harlan was like
spearheading this project to record all
that with live instruments but duplicate
all the granular interactivity and the
crazy thing is if you hit f12 it will
cross frayed the music like on that
exact beat to the original or bad don't
they put so much work into that feature
which is basically for nerds like me and
point oh one percent of other similar
becomes so cool so that was one where
the remaster it simultaneously elevated
the quality immensely while paying
enormous respect to the original I was
like this is the perfect way to do this
so great try I want to know why you were
hiding when I asked Austin the question
about oh my god because we'll be here
for a whole other hour as far as like
like Nick Drake Pink Moon the the low
fidelity of that is what makes it so
great and and understanding the Dark
Side of the Moon the way that they made
that record a day in the life for
Beatles the fact that they went between
all three rooms of Abbey Road and ran
and hit play and record on each machine
because there was no simply
link those things together it's like
that's part of the narrative and you
shouldn't I look there there's a there's
a version of this where you say yes I
want to make this accessible to a whole
new generation but I always say create
don't record don't recreate just just
try to create something new
take the
separation take the emulation and be
different do something new with that
idea and that doesn't mean like oh we're
gonna we're gonna make ghostbusters with
girls now and I'm not saying do that
let Ghostbusters be Ghostbusters and
create something new we're all still
telling the same story it's it's a boy
meets a girl it's a boy and his dog it's
it's always the same story the hero's
journey
it's just find a new interesting way
that's why I think you two still one of
the greatest bands in Bono is when the
most amazing lyricist don't make the
South Park reference right now Austin
because because he takes a simple
thought and puts it in a very novel way
the lyrics are always like that's what
I've been trying to say Shakespeare I
Austin I had I had a season pass one
year to compose Earl and it was one of
the worst musical parts I ever went to
just depression go ahead a lot if I talk
about the history of my industry if it's
games media or even content creation in
general it's so funny because looking
back at the archives of games media is
like IGN had a babe section so young
that the biggest change that I see in
actual games journalism or its media's
probably the correct word is just that
all of the outlets used to have like a
part where they put women in bikinis for
some reason I think some websites still
have a GN we at one point took a bunch
down like without permission was just
like I'm gonna delete that that's a bit
often in the movies that are written
like Lara Croft is a sexy chick it's
still really bad but that's what he
doesn't notice
age I'll sorry I'll throw this one they
are just building upon a lot alone Oh
watch The Beastie Boys documentary
that's that's that that's some great
homework just that it is so it is it is
so so good whether you are a fan of
Beastie Boys I am but whether you're a
fan or not it is it is insightful it is
educational it is it's provocative it's
entertaining it's it's great it's
absolutely great so I can't but they
they hit on that specifically as far as
like here we're poster boys for misogyny
and how much they have changed and it's
it's just it's almost impossible to
believe that the two people that are on
stage are ad-rock and Mike Dee it's
crazy so alrighty on that note I'll
watch that sometime this week thank you
for the homework yeah thank you everyone
for joining us for this episode we will
see you all next week
myyy